hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about
bloating
indigestion
constipation and acid reflux
if you have one or more of these this
video is for you now i just want to make
it really really simple because what's
being taught out there is completely the
opposite of what you need to know
to correct these symptoms now there's
only really
kind of four
things you need to know okay got the
stomach liver gallbladder pancreas okay
so the stomach's right here
gall blood livers here gallbladder and
pancreas okay so the stomach breaks down
food the purpose of the stomach is to
break down mainly proteins
and absorb
minerals okay calcium iron potassium
those are the two big functions not to
mention kill off microbes and bacteria
and things like that so it needs to be
very very very very very very acid okay
between one and three if you know about
ph that's like that's like really really
low okay
now
if that ph
is not acid enough
you will not be able to have that acid
trigger
the liver to release the gallbladder
fluid which is bile so let me explain
what bile is biome is a fluid
to help you break down fats
and it actually extracts
fat soluble vitamins
it helps you absorb
fatty acids healthy fats which basically
make up all your cells
so this is a very very important organ
so we have the bile that's made by the
liver but it's stored by the gallbladder
okay if you don't have a gallbladder
well then you have a tube but you still
have bile that comes out and you're
usually going to be deficient so a lot
of times
if the stomach is not strong enough it
won't release the bile so now you have a
bile deficiency then you're going to get
bloating
so we have a primary stomach problem
secondary gallbladder problem okay
one of the main symptoms for gallbladder
is burping belching and right shoulder
pain
then we've got the pancreas the pancreas
does a lot of stuff but the main thing
it does with digestion is it makes
most of the enzymes in the body enzymes
break down food different like carb you
have enzymes for carbohydrates starches
proteins fats okay so these little guys
work together they break down the food
and and then they end up in a small
intestine where microbes go in there and
break down even more okay so really if
this stomach is not acidic enough you
can't release the bile and you can't
release the pancreas as well as and so
you get this situation when you get
undigested food okay that rots and it
sits right here
and not to mention all the other issues
with you know pain stomach pain bloating
constipation
and then if this ph isn't strong enough
this valve right here won't close and
they call that gerd
okay they call the acid reflux because
the acid is going to come up here so
acid reflux is really is a situation we
have not enough acid okay
so
what do people take
anti-acids
oh my gosh what a mistake because now
not only did you not fix anything you
made it worse
okay so let me show you what i do now i
usually do a combination i probably use
these two remedies right here
and i'll explain them in a bit
probably 99
together i use them together because
i'll tell you why a lot of the symptoms
from the stomach could mimic the
symptoms from the pancreas that can
mimic the symptoms from the gallbladder
so a lot of times it can cross over and
it's hard to know what is causing what
so the first thing i do is i really
acidify the stomach and i use something
called a concentrated acidifier called
apple cider vinegar plus which has
a lot of apple cider vinegar in a
concentrated powder pill with betaine
hydrochloride which is an acidifier so
you take like two or three with the meal
right before you eat and that starts to
acidify the stomach okay that corrects
the stomach
and that alone
will really help the bile to be released
and the pancreas to be released so this
is a very
powerful
common
commonly used product that i use in a
lot of people because so many people
have a problem with this especially as
they age they lose the stomach acid and
the list goes on and on and on of all
the reasons why they have low stomach
acids now this other thing i use which
is gallbladder formula has
some actual purified bile salts in it
which helps
it helps give what your body's missing a
lot of times if you don't have enough
bile this gives you what you're missing
and it really
helps you fortify the liver and the
gallbladder to digest and for bloating
but if the stomach is not acid sometimes
on a rare case you take gallbladder and
you might alkalize because because the
gallbladder is alkaline alkalize this
problem and make you a little bit worse
but that's rare but it can happen
so if someone takes the gallbladder
without the acidifiers sometimes they'll
feel more bloating so i just say add the
acidifier boom everything works out nice
okay so with that bile
in there now you can lubricate the whole
colon that's what helps the constipation
okay also helps the absorption of
vitamin a for the eyes the skin the
sinuses
that's vitamin a deficiencies okay
also the in the gallbladder formula i
actually have pancreatic enzymes
so now a gallbladder actually helps both
of these areas at the same time so it
actually gets the pancreas to work
better
and it gets the gallbladder work better
and then we add the acidifier to really
make it work better so this will handle
a lot of problems a combination of these
two right here so you would take the
gallbladder stuff after you eat take one
that's all you need after you eat and
take the acidifier the apple cider
vinegar plus right before you eat
i usually like to take a little bit like
two or three of the
apple cider vinegar or tablets and then
i like to take one gallbladder after i
eat to get a full digestion you'll find
they'd be very very satisfied because
you start pulling in more fats into the
cell so when you actually get complete
digestion
the food can no longer sit right here
anymore so you don't have that food
that's like indigested it's kind of
undigested sitting right there
you don't get any more bloating you get
a complete digestion so you get see
constipation is incomplete digestion and
it's usually stuck right here
and so the food can actually go through
effectively and you get more energy you
feel better so these are the two that i
use for bloating indigestion
constipation acid reflux and
they work really powerfully together so
give it a shot and write your comments
below